oui
bonsoir à tous merci d'être ici ce soir
c'est vraiment un plaisir immense que de
vous savoir prêt à accueillir des idées
inspirantes
je m'appelle au d'emilie aude tirait
angie je sais c'est un peu compliqué
j'avais une maman qui voulait m'appeler
aude et non pas préféré émis finalement
ils ont uni leurs forces et choisi de
m'appeler aude trait d'union emilie mon
identité est le fruit d'un compromis
entre deux personnes très différentes
puisque mon père était antillais et que
ma maman et picarde
alors évidemment ce sont deux
départements français joue la corde
et pourtant ce sont deux continents de
culture de langue de religion et même de
couleur de peau différente
et puis un jour j'avais 14 ans cette
union a volé en éclats et pour la
première fois de ma vie j'ai vu la
différence entre mes deux parents
j'ai vu la frontière s'est installée
entre eux ils n'étaient plus
complémentaires mais complètement
opposées noir d'un côté et blanc de
l'autre comme dans un jeu d'échecs alors
au début j'ai cru qu'il allait falloir
choisir mon camp être blanche ou être
noir
mais comment choisir entre mon père et
ma mère
alors finalement j'ai décidé d'avancer
au milieu entre les cases
j'ai décidé d'habiter la frontière
consciemment pour moi c'était un peu
comme faire une randonnée sur un chemin
de crête de là haut
j'avais l'impression que nous étions
encore ensemble
j'avais cette vision d'ensemble et donc
j'avais l'impression que nous étions
encore ensemble
habiter la frontière c'était très
rassurant parce que c'était une façon de
ne pas prendre parti mais la ligne de
crête
je ne sais pas si vous la voyez bien
c'est très étroit pour avancer il faut
être très prudent m lentement un pas un
pied devant l'autre et puis surtout se
faire tout petit parce que sinon c'est
la chute
alors c'est un paradoxe mais habité la
frontière c'est très rassurant et en
même temps c'est habité la peur et puis
un jour à l'occasion d'un voyage à
l'étranger
j'ai découvert un jeu qui s'appelle le
paradoxe justement c'est un genre de
puissance 4 où l'objectif c'est
d'aligner quatre billes de la même
couleur blanche ou noire
le paradoxe c'est que pour déplacer une
bille blanche par exemple et l'aligner
avec les autres il faut impérativement
qu'elle soit accompagnée d'une bille
noire l'une ne peut pas avancer sans
l'autre et ça veut même dire que par
moment pour pouvoir déplacer l'une de
vos billes
il va falloir accepter que ça puisse
aussi profiter à votre adversaire
je ne sais pas qui a inventé ce jeu le
paradoxe mais vraiment c'est quelqu'un
que j'aimerais rencontrer parce que
malgré son apparente simplicité ce jeu
révèle une vraie philosophie du
compromis et l'idée selon laquelle dans
la vie on n'est rien sur les autres
alors cette idée petit à petit a fait
son chemin chez moi et j'ai décidé j'ai
décidé d'habiter la frontière
consciemment j'ai décidé de pratiquer en
fait voilà de pratiquer ce que j'appelle
aujourd'hui le paradoxe de la frontière
c'est à dire que j'habite fièrement la
frontière parce qu'elle me définit elle
me traverse littéralement elle me fait
tenir debout et en même temps j'ai
conscience que pour avancer il faut que
j'associe ce qui les as de blanc en noir
en moi est ce qu'il ya de noir en moins
aude trait d'union
emilie et ça va plus loin parce que
habiter la frontière ces livres à
l'intersection à l'endroit où tout se
réunit j'en ai pris conscience quand
j'ai commencé à voyager et que j'ai eu
la surprise de me sentir comme chez moi
dans des pays dans des villes aussi
différentes que toronto dakar rome tel
aviv ou beyrouth
et puis ce sentiment s'est encore
renforcé quand j'ai commencé à faire du
couch surfing
je ne sais pas si vous connaissez le
principe c'est de dormir chez l'habitant
vous êtes accueillis chez quelqu'un qui
accepte gratuitement de vous laisser
dormir sur son canapé et il m'est même
arrivé que des gens que je n'avais pas
rencontré me laisse les clés de leur
maison et même de leur voiture dans la
boîte aux lettres en toute confiance
donc si vous ne connaissez pas je vous
conseille vivement de tenter
l'expérience parce que passer la petite
appréhension
au début on ne sait pas trop où on va
mettre les pieds et puis finalement on
rencontre plein de gens différents qui
vous font entrer dans leur intimité qui
vous font découvrir leurs endroits
préférés qui vous vous présenter leurs
amis leurs familles même parfois et qui
finalement le temps d'un voyage vont
vous sans vous faire sentir chez vous
partout et peu à peu et bien c'est ma
famille qui s'est agrandie et qui s'est
enrichie
de culture de langue et de couleurs
différentes et pourtant le couch surfing
ça n'est rien de plus qu'un bon vieux
principe qu'on pratique depuis la nuit
des temps et qui s'appelle l'hospitalité
chez les grecs de l'antiquité par
exemple la philoxenia il appelait ça la
philo xing l'amour de l'étranger
littéralement même l'amour de l'inconnu
eh bien c'était une valeur cardinale
sacré c'était même un devoir et à
l'époque on évaluer le degré de
civilisation d'une société à la façon de
rennes accueillait les étrangers dans
l'odyssée d'homère par exemple glisse au
cours de son périple à khost dans l'île
des faits anciens
ils ne savent rien de lui ils ne le
connaissent pas et pourtant ils
l'accueillent comme un roi pour lui il
organise un banquet
ils font chanter et réciter des poèmes
sont l'honneur et puis avant de le
laisser repartir il le couvre
littéralement de cadeaux voilà le modèle
de civilisation que promeut au maire
nous on se dit les héritiers de la grèce
antique de cette grande civilisation qui
nous a légué la philosophie la
démocratie la littérature le théâtre
mais quand on fait cet héritage
aujourd'hui la philoxenia a disparu de
notre vocabulaire la xénophobie bien la
peur de l'étranger elle par contre elle
vit de beaux jours la preuve c'est que
en moins de 30 ans depuis la mieux
depuis la chute du mur de berlin 1989
on a reconstruit plus de 60 murs aux
frontières plus de 69 et sans s'en
rendre compte
on sent mûr parce que le paradoxe du mur
c'est qu'il protège autant qu il
emprisonne
alors comment résister à ça moi
j'appartiens à aucune association aucun
parti politique ce qu'une simple
citoyenne mais j'ai dans la tête une
petite phrase que disait stéphane hessel
et qui met vraiment qui me tient à coeur
que je vous livre stéphane hessel disait
résister c'est créer et créer c'est
résister alors je fais que ce que j'ai
je crains c'est à dire que par exemple
en ce moment je suis en train de
travailler à au développement d'une
expérience en réalité virtuelle en
partenariat avec migreurop
l'observatoire des frontières l'idée
c'est avec un casque sur les oreilles
sur les yeux de s'immerger dans un monde
en trois dimensions
on peut créer une nouvelle réalité où on
peut inventer de nouvelles règles et
notamment s'affranchir de la matérialité
de la frontière où on peut par exemple
décidé de traverser une frontière comme
un passe muraille où on peut décider de
la rendre pour eux aux échanges on peut
décider de l'effacer comme une rature
sur une page sur une page blanche
et c'est important parce que aujourd'hui
nous sommes du bon côté de la frontière
mais demain dans l'histoire rien et
éternelle ce qui fait notre réalité
aujourd'hui nos pays nos identités nos
frontières en fait tout ça n'a jamais
cessé d'évoluer
jamais et c'est tant mieux parce que la
vie c'est le mouvement
c'est un fait constant dans l'histoire
de l'humanité
l'homme s'est toujours déplacées
toujours c'est dans sa nature que d'être
curieux que d'avoir envie de voir ce qui
se cache derrière cette montagne au-delà
de cette mer malgré les dangers et c'est
comme ça que peu à peu nous avons peuple
et l'intégralité de la planète que les
sociétés sont les que les cultures ont
évolué à coups de vagues migratoires
successives et ininterrompue le slogan
des conférences ted sais pas s'il est
ici d'ailleurs je vous le remet en tête
c'est à dire the wedding boat people who
was trying to il n'y a pas que les
bonnes idées qui méritent d'être pro tak
propager et qui change le monde et aussi
les gens qui les portent
alors moi depuis 2000 en 2012 eh bien
j'ai proposé à france culture une
émission radio sur l'histoire des
migrations internationales
j'ai décidé d'appeler cette émission les
hommes aux semelles de vent
à ce jour j'ai produit près de 40
documentaire sur l'émigration et je peux
vous dire que s'il ya une chose dont je
suis convaincu c'est que sur cette
question nous sommes pétris d'idées
reçues
prenez les frontières naturelles par
exemple les frontières que l'on dit
naturel en fait elles ne le sont jamais
dans les pyrénées par exemple la
frontière entre l'espagne et la france
pas sur la ligne de crête elle a coupé
des chemins de transhumance
multimillénaire sans pour autant réussir
à couper les liens de solidarité entre
catalan français et espagnols qui se
sont accueillis mutuellement pendant la
première guerre mondiale et la dictature
franquiste
même chose pour la méditerranée la mer
méditerranée qu'on considère aujourd'hui
comme étant la frontières extérieures de
l'europe
en fait pendant des siècles ça a été un
vaste échange de communication et d'un
d'intenses échanges entre des cultures
aussi différentes que les grecs les
romains les phéniciens les normands les
hautement les carthaginois l'air les
arabes enfin tous ces peuples ont
sillonné la mer méditerranée et ils ont
laissé dans le paysage et dans les modes
de vie des traces qu'on peut encore
admirer aujourd'hui que ce soit dans les
îles ou sur les ou sur les bords sur les
rivages de la mer méditerranée
moi j'ai l'habitude de dire que
l'histoire de l'humanité s'est écrite
avec les pieds mais ça n'est dans aucun
livre d'histoire parce qu'on réduit la
question des migrations a une dimension
politique alors que c'est une réalité
historique et anthropologique
moi je suis métisse et pour vous faire
comprendre cette méconnaissance des gens
à l'égard des migrations en tant que
métis il m'arrive assez fréquemment de
rencontrer des gens qui ne comprennent
pas que je puisse être française qui
refuse même l'idée que je puisse être
française simplement à cause de cette
couleur de peau alors la frontière
justement il me semble que c'est comme
la peau ça doit respirer ça doit
communiquer certes c'est la limite de
mon territoire de mon corps mais en même
temps c'est par là que mon corps respire
et puis surtout c'est la porte d'entrée
par laquelle j'entre en contact avec les
autres parra par laquelle je m'unis aux
autres alors pour conclure j'aimerais
vous faire part de ce qui est pour moi
le plus grand enseignement de ces cinq
années passées au celsa
on m'a appris à sortir du cadre think
out of the box
je pense que vous avez tous entendu cinq
mille fois eh bien je pense qu'on peut
changer de paradigme qu'on peut faire
évoluer une représentation sur la
frontière qu'on peut la voir comme un
trait d'union et que même si on veut on
peut rajouter des petites flèches au
bout pour en faire des vecteurs des
connecteurs avec l'extérieur avec les
autres c'est ce que fait par exemple le
célèbre street artist banksy qui
viendraient en cisjordanie un hôtel face
au mur de séparation entre israéliens et
palestiniens
il y accueille des gens qui viennent du
monde entier pour se confronter à la
réalité du terrain
au delà de tout ce qui ce qu'on peut
entendre dans les médias sur le conflit
israélo-palestinien et banques si les
invite à s'exprimer sur le mur de
de séparation il les invite à investir
cet espace à le rendre vivant à le faire
vivre
parce que la frontière ça n'est pas un
no man's land
je le sais j'y habite alors il ne tient
qu'à nous de faire des frontières des
lieux des changes de communication de
rencontre de dialogue parce que ce qui
fait notre humanité
c'est justement notre capacité à nous
relier aux autres à être des traits
d'union
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]